en un an les restos du coeur ont
accueilli huit cent soixante mille
personnes avec l'aide de 72000 bénévoles
dans 2027 centre sur l'ensemble du
territoire national avec 130 millions de
repas distribués en un an l'aide
alimentaire reste l'un des principaux
piliers de l'action de l'association
fondée par coluche en bourgogne franche
comté sur un an les 3740 bénévoles ont
accueilli près de quarante mille
bénéficiaires pour un nombre de repas
servis de près de 6 millions sept cent
soixante mille en plus des denrées
alimentaires et du vestiaire depuis
plusieurs années les restos du coeur ont
diversifié leurs activités pour répondre
aux situations des personnes accueillies
par exemple l'accès au droit les
ateliers de français le soutien à la
recherche d'emploi l'insertion par
l'activité économique ou encore
l'hébergement d'urgence